despite being nearly isolated in the world stage,
Russia still has more allies than you might think.
Belarus is the biggest supporter of Russia,
allowing putin's
forces to freely move through its territory.
in the Middle East,
Iran remains one of moscow's most reliable
regional partners.
in fact, the regime recently agreed to help Russia
manufacture war drones to fight Ukraine.
putin's Russia also has the unwavering support of Syria,
with Assad sending troops to fight
alongside Russian forces
last spring. in Asia,
Moscow managed to forge closer ties with North Korea.
some reports suggest that the Hermit Kingdom has been
shipping munitions to Russia,
although Pyongyang has repeatedly denied
these allegations.
across the Pacific, Cuba
continues to be one of putin's loudest cheerleaders,
fully adopting the Kremlins narrative about Ukraine.
the same can be said of Venezuela,
the key Geo
strategic ally of Russia,
who was one of the first to publicly back putin's war.
finally, Russia has expanded its tactical cooperation
with Nicaragua,
a nation that gave Moscow
full authority to deploy military
assets on its territory as of June.